un bombardement de la plus grande flotte que la
marine ait jamais assemblé une centaine d'obus
par minute jusqu'à ce qu'ils se rendent cher Dieu
mr.  lien et je les déteste tous je fais je suis un
homme avec des préjugés Le congrès ne doit jamais
déclarer égaux ceux que Dieu a créés
inégaux
tu vas essayer de faire passer l'amendement
pour abolir l'esclavage non ne gaspille pas ce
pouvoir le premier février
j'ai l'intention de signer le  Le treizième
amendement, un combat comme celui-ci est à
mort o les hommes du sud viennent
proposer la paix abolissant l'esclavage règle
le destin des millions maintenant en servitude
mais des millions à naître à venir c'est soit
l'amendement soit cette paix confédérée
vous ne pouvez pas avoir réservé l'esclavage monsieur c'est
fait  même si chaque républicain vote oui, il
nous manquerait encore 20 voix, seulement 20 est
la loi même sans valeur indigne, vous
devriez être traité de la même manière devant la
loi, ces bateaux doivent être
achetés.  n'achetez pas
les votes vous voyez ce que vous pouvez faire pensez
à tous les garçons qui meurent si vous ne faites pas la
paix je ne peux pas mettre fin à cette guerre jusqu'à ce que nous
nous guérissions de l'esclavage cet amendement
est ce remède dont nous avons besoin  sortez juste d'
ici, attrapez-le mais maintenant je suis le président
des États-Unis revêtu d'un immense
pouvoir, vous me procurerez ces fonds
[Musique]
ils risquent tout la guerre sera finie dans
un mois, nous sommes assurés de tout perdre
abattez-moi je vote
Yancy la Constitution seul aujourd'hui nous
voterons dieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi